SCP-682 Vs SCP-513. Sometimes, to
take down a scary SCP like SCP-682,
you need to bring in an even scarier SCP, like
this demonic cowbell and the phantom it reveals.
SCP-682 was partially incinerated and brought
into a testing chamber, where a robot arm rang
the SCP-513 bell several times, with the resulting
sound causing extreme stress for SCP-682.
Aerosolized tranquilizers and sedatives were
pumped into the chamber, causing 682 to fall
unconscious. It then began sleepwalking,
breaching the containment chamber, but it
wasn’t alone: A nightmarish, ghost-like entity,
resembling SCP-682, began stalking the halls.
After mass hysteria and mass
staff death across the site,
the Foundation finally got things back
under control. When SCP-682 was woken up,
it complained, saying that it
was having such a lovely dream...